so every major government agency at your
expense publishes hundreds of pages of
guidelines that promote absurd
anti-white woke propaganda
Wall Street Journal just obtained
documents from NASA which warrant of
something called micro inequities they
also learned the Department of Veterans
Affairs as they quote gender gingerbread
person
it's also depressing if you think about
it it's one thing if it's happening at
the Small Business Association but if
it's happening at the Pentagon it's a
huge problem and it is
the Army now advises soldiers not to
have any quote discomfort Sharon with a
female who has male genitalia really
so some dude's going to get in the
shower with you pretending to be a girl
and if you don't like it you're the
weirdo so a lot of soldiers are just
leaving over all of this Ivan ricklin is
one of them he served 25 years as a both
Lieutenant Colonel Ander Green Beret but
the moment the pentagons are promoting
vax mandates and Equity training he left
he retired now we asked him about that
decision a very sad decision from his
point of view in a brand new episode of
Tucker Carlson today here's part of the
conversation
we've gone away from the focus of
fighting and winning our nation's Wars
and defending the Constitution
if we get back to that I think we'll be
in a better position to start to repel
from foreign adversaries which I kind of
pivoted and talked about namely
obviously the biggest one is China
also Russia is helping and advise I
would I would argue to make sure it
expedites our demise Iran is probably
right there not in a close third but in
third place
do you know the answer you raised a
really interesting point when you said
if you're going to remind the entire
military force
what its job is which is to defend the
Constitution and that's to know the
Constitution thank you so if I ask the
question of
secretary Austin
chairman of Joint Chiefs of Staff Millie
if I ask you General
um what are you going to do on the 25th
amendment's violated
oh you don't know what the 25th
amendment is how about what are you
going to do in the 12th amendments
violated
oh you don't know that one let me go to
the base document what about Article 2
Section one Clause 2 or Article 1
Section four most of these people are
going to look at you like deer in the
headlights I have no clue what you're
talking about the thing is that our
entire institutions have been
through the media have pushed this
whether it's all three branches of
federal government even at the state
level have been pushing this narrative
uh to make people think that this is
actually a the extremism thing is a
thing and it only applies to one side of
the political ideology
and so in a sense some folks are
convinced that that's true even though
it's not it's not based on fact
others know that critical thinkers I
would say majority of my network is in
the special ops and Intel community
and those that are even lean left of
center
when I present the evidence in a very
deliberate systematic manner
they know where I stand ideologically
they'll agree with the conclusion
which does not align with what's been
Pro what's being promulgated at the top
but they don't want to lose their job
they don't want to lose their you know
benefits it all comes down to that it
all comes down to safety security and
they're willing to bend and budge on
their moral ethical and even legal
principles
foreign that full conversation on Fox
Nation right now
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight